ministers unanimous Lisztomania almost  blew that only revealed an American  farmer opposed in the country but  impractical zhaveri ready if not I would  watch it on a Franciscan I think this is  a victory for all a victory for all  European farmers in their strife for a  balanced and fair business environments  we had other issues as well agriculture  and climate change and I know it very  carefully the views of ministers  particularly in relation to the  flexibilities that are available in the  effort sharing decision on organics I  welcome the general view that has been  expressed by many member states that we  should continue our work to reach an  acceptable compromise we want to ensure  that the integrity of the organic sector  is maintained that it is a growing  sector of nine percent per annum and in  that regard we have to take account of  the concerns of consumers who are paying  a premium price for the products that  they purchase which are labeled as  organic